Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke. Herr Peter Neuberger ist 63 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß, 82 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Neuberger stellte sich heute bei uns seit 4 bis 6 Wochen bestehender Stuhlgang Veränderung vor.
Den Patienten zufolge sei der Stuhl manchmal brech, manchmal fest geworden und der Patient habe kein Blut im Stuhl bemerkt.
Wie können Sie diese Beschwerde formulieren?
Aufwechselnd.
Der Patient habe aufwechselnde Obst und Diarrhea.
Jetzt erinnere ich mich an nicht Herr Oberarzt. Ich wusste diese Fachbegriffe aber leider momentan erinnere ich mich nicht. Darf ich weitermachen?
Ja.
Der Patient berichtete über Dyspnoe, Gewichtsabnahme von 3 bis 4 Kilogramm innerhalb von einem Monat, nächtliche Hyperhidrose und Palo auch Fatigue.
Die Fragen nach Tussis, Tachikade, Palpitations, Fieber, Schüterfrost und Abdominalgie wurden verneint.
Der Patient war früher bei anderem Arzt nicht und hatte keine Koloskopie.
Bei der Veketative Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt. Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen, Nausea ohne Emesis, er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und 4 mal Covid Infektion geimpft.
Er hatte Anfallerkrankungen, nannte seit 10 Jahren bestehende Arterielle Hypertonie, seit 20 Jahren bestehende Cox Arthrose und seit 12 Jahren bestehende Hemoroide.
Er nehme Walzartan morgens und holte 50 mg Tabletten bei Bedarf 2 bis 3 Mal pro Woche ein.
Er benutze eine Salbe gegen Hemoroide. Der Name von Salbe und die Dosierung von Walzartan sollte geklärt werden.
Vor 20 Jahren habe er sich bei einem Unfall eine Schülterfraktur zugezogen, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
Der Patient hatte Allergien gegen Novalgin, die sich durch Pusteln äußert und er hatte Fructoseintoleranz, die sich durch Meteorismus äußert.
Er sei Raucher und er rauche 5 bis 6 Zigaretten täglich seit 20 Jahren. Er trinke 1 bis 2 Flaschen Bier täglich. Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater an Darmpolypen leidet und wohnt in einem alten Heim. Die Mutter leidet an Diabetes mellitus und Diabetische Fuss.
Er habe eine Schwester, die gesund sei und der Patient sei geschieden, habe 3 gesunde Kinder und wohne mit seiner Partnerin.
Er sei seit 9 Monaten arbeitslos. Früher habe er in einem Baugewerbe gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Kolonkarzinom aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter nächtliche Hyperhydrose, Gewichtsabnahme von 3 bis 4 kg innerhalb von einem Monat,
Dyspne und auch Palo, chronische Fatigue und Stuhlkonsistenz wechseln.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Kolonkarzinom. Als Differenz der Diagnosen kommen Reizdarmsyndrom, chronische entzündliche Erkrankungen in Betracht.
Zunächst würde ich bei den Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob eine Hautfarbeveränderungen, geschwollene Lymphknoten, Druckschmerzen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Leukocytosal, BSG, CAP, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten, Gerümmungsparameter, Tumormarkes bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Abdominalzoonographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine CT-Abdomens fernlassen, um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Danach würde ich eine Koloskopie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen und meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und einen Venosynzugang legen und Antisphasmolitikum verabreichen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich ein chirurgisches und ein onkologisches Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Oberst, Sie können bei der körperlichen Untersuchung einen Kolonkarzinom diagnostizieren.
Sie können die Tumore abtasten, wenn der Tumor in der rektalen Region vorhanden ist.
Wie oft liegt Kolonkarzinom im rektalen Bereich?
Ich habe keine detaillierte Information darüber. Ich habe nur grundlegende Kenntnisse.
Ich denke, dass es ungefähr 50% ist. Aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben gesagt, als differential Diagnose, denke ich, eine chronische Darmensünnung.
Wenn der Patient eine chronische Darmensünnung hat, haben Sie mögliche Komplikationen?
Ja, wir können Füße, Darmabseß und Perforation bei der chronischen Erkrankung beobachten.
Was empfinde ich den Patienten? Welche Stadium hat sie zuerst?
Wenn der Patient Stadium 4 hat, bedeutet das Metastase. Ich würde Palliativmedizin empfehlen.
Aber wenn die Stadium 1, 2 oder 3, würde ich eine Operation und nach der Operation Chemotherapie oder Radiotherapie empfehlen.
Wie können wir das Stadium legen? Nur eine körperliche Untersuchung oder nur eine Abdommelzynographie?
Nein, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung können wir die Vergrößerung der Liftknoten abtasten.
Dann können wir eine PET-CT durchführen, um die Metastase genau zu beurteilen.
Dann können wir das Studium des TUMORs genau bestätigen.
Welche Klappifikationen haben Sie während des Studiums erfahren?
Ja, TNM-Klappflaskalifikationen haben wir.
Also M-Metastase, N-Vergrößerung der Liftknoten, T-Große und die lokale Einteilung des TUMORs.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde in diesem Fall eine Koloskopie durchführen. Können Sie uns Koloskopie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich würde gerne Sie über Koloskopie aufklären.
Koloskopie ist die endoskopische Untersuchung des Diktams.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Verletzungen, Erntzündungen, TUMORe und andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung schieben wir einen dünnen, flexiblen Optischen Schlauch durch den Aftar bis in das Blinddarm vor.
Der Darm muss leer sein. Deswegen benötigen Sie eine Darmreinigung.
Deswegen sollen Sie eine Abfüllmittel bevor der Untersuchung trinken.
Ich trinke.
Der Patient soll eine Abfüllmittel vor der Untersuchung trinken, um eine Darmreinigung zu machen.
Diese Untersuchung kann sowohl zu diagnostischen als auch therapeutischen Zwecken benutzt werden.
Während der Untersuchung können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen oder kleine Polypen oder TUMORe entfernen.
In der Regel erhält der Patient ein leichtes Schlafmittel während der Untersuchung.
Es gibt einige Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung wie zum Beispiel Nachblutungen oder Verletzung der Schleimhäute.
Nach der Untersuchung sollen Sie ein paar Stunden zu beobachten bei uns bleiben.
Nach der Untersuchung soll man keine wichtigen Sachen machen wie zum Beispiel Autofahren oder wichtige Verträge unterschreiben.
Der Patient soll eine begleitende Person mitbringen, die den Patient nach Hause bringt.
Wie lange dauert die Darmreinigung?
Der Patient soll am Abend drei Liter trinken und am Morgen auch andere drei Liter trinken, um die Reinigung zu machen.
Was trinken? Tee, Cola?
Wasser.
Nur Wasser ist genug.
Trinken trinken drei Liter Wasser.
Mit der Abfüllmittel.
Darf der Patient festessen?
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient ein paar...
Vor der Untersuchung? Ich frage.
Vor der Untersuchung soll der Patient ein paar Stunden, also sechs Stunden vor der Untersuchung nicht mehr essen.
Aber er kann trinken.
Unser Lehrer hat uns gesagt, der Patient vor der Untersuchung Tag am Morgen nur leichte Frühstück machen.
Dann darf der Patient keine feste Speise oder Essen konsumieren.
Keine. Aber der Patient darf Wasser trinken oder Frühstück trinken.
Am Abend soll der Patient ein Liter Wasser mit Abfüllmittel trinken und dann viel Wasser trinken.
Vor der Untersuchung ungefähr vier Stunden.
Der Patient soll ein Liter Wasser mit Abfüllmittel trinken und dann viel Wasser trinken, um ihr Darm genau zu reinigen.
Okay, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, bitte gehen Sie in unser Infodisk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Vielen Dank. Das ist sehr nett von Ihnen, Herr Oberarzt.